so operation finale your character
spends a lot of time in this film lying
lying about who he is lying about his
intentions I'm sort of wondering as an
actor what the key is to effectively
lying on screen to effectively saying
lines that your character may not or
knows is not true well Vinnie I I take
issue with the fact that he was lying
because whenever he expressed pride in
what he had done this is the man who
said I will leap laughing into my grave
knowing that I take the cells of six
million with me so the act of
manipulation was probably his his his
greatest tool in in destroying or
attempting to destroy all of Europe's
Jews so I think I would persuade you to
think of it as being him being
manipulative rather than a liar because
it what he said was rooted in truth his
truth there is a point in the film where
he says what is truth whose truth so I
think that perhaps you know one can
ponder on that as to whether he's
speaking from the heart whether he's
lying certainly I believe that he is
telling the truth when he says that that
Peters sister is not worth the spit in
his mouth but that is said to revoke
Peter into plunging more of the of that
stuff into his veins that though so he
manipulates himself into hopefully being
killed before he gets to Israel that he
got to Israel and just to sort of
piggyback off of that I was gonna ask
you what kind of conversations you had
with Oscar about where you wanted the
two characters to be in from moment to
moment what what sort of relationship
you wanted them to have in that moment
compared to sort of when one of them is
riling up the other and one of them is
not lying I will not say not the
conversations like that don't take place
on the film set actors first if they're
if they are cast correctly by Chris as I
believe we were work from a basis of
truth but that's a tacit truth
that silently acknowledged between the
two the debate about scenes did not take
place we understood perfectly our
characters are individual processes both
of whom are trying to manipulate the
other and you must let that breathe you
can talk it away I don't talk it away if
I'm a portrait artist I have to allow
myself to look at the character I'm
portraying dip my brushes into the paint
and apply it to the canvas and there is
no debate it has to it has to flow
unfortunately Oscar and I trusted each
other so much and Chris the director was
so steeped in his mandate for for making
that film that the the conversations
actually were minimal and it was very
very intuitive there's a there's a
moment particular I want to don't ask
you about where it's it's after you're
captured it's you're you're sort of
laying in this ditch and you and you let
out this scream that sort of made me
feel so bad for your character even
knowing who he is
knowing type of person he is I'm
wondering if you were looking for small
moments like that where where the
audience has just such a mixed sort of
even guilty feeling toward your
character I don't think I I contrived
anything I hope not because that that
any contrivance the camera will spot
immediately and so will the audience
that scream came out of the circumstance
and the proximity to his house and the
the reliance he had on his Nazi son and
that scream just came out of me at the
right time I hope for the right reasons
and was fortunately caught on camera so
it's a combination of skill and
intuition
you